FIRST IT'S TIME FOR A NEW
SEGMENT WE'RE CALLING "JUST
BECAUSE IT'S SAD DOESN'T MEAN
YOU CAN PRETEND IT'S NOT
HAPPENING."
♪
>> Larry: GUYS, GUYS.
I DON'T REALLY FEEL LIKE THAT
MUSIC REALLY MATCHES THE TONE OF
THE PIECE.
A LITTLE TOO HAPPY MUSIC.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT.
SO ANYHOW THIS IS WHEN WE TACKLE
A STORY SO SAD MOST NEWS
OUTLET'S IGNORE IT TONIGHT WE'RE
TALKING  ABOUT HAITI.
FRANKLY NO ONE ELSE WILL.
SORRY, SEAN PENN, I WAS
REFERRING TO EVERYONE ELSE.
TRYING TO TAKE CREDIT.
HAITI IS STILL REELING FROM THE
EARTHQUAKE THAT HIT IT FIVE
YEARS AGO.
>> JANUARY 12th, 2010.
CATASTROPHIC EARTHQUAKE RAVAGED
HAITI'S CAPITOL, PUERTO PRINCE.
LEAVING 1.5 MILLION PEOPLE
HOMELESS.
>> Larry: 1.5 MILLION PEOPLE OR
AS DONALD TRUMP CALLS THEM
LOSERS.
AFTER THE EARTHQUAKE THE WORLD
SPRUNG INTO ACTION.
>> THE AMERICAN RED CROSS RAISED
NEARLY $500 MILLION FOR HAITI.
A YEAR AFTER, THE RED CROSS
ANNOUNCED PLANS TO CREATE
"BRAND NEW COMMUNITIES."
>> Larry: BRAND NEW COMMUNITIES,
GREAT.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE HOW
$500 MILLION TO TRANSFORM THIS
INTO THIS ESPECIALLY AT HAITI
PRICES.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
COOL, MAN.
FIVE YEARS.
OKAY.
WELL, HAITI HAS TO BE BRIMMING
WITH HOMES BY NOW, RIGHT.
>> THE REPORT SAYS HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS IN DONATIONS
AFTER THE QUAKE WERE MISS SPENT.
A PROMISE TO PROVIDE PERMANENT
HOUSING RESULTED IN SIX
HOMES BEING BUILT.
>> Larry: SIX!
SIX HOMES?
WITH HALF A BILLION DOLLARS.
GOOD LORD THAT'S --
THAT'S $83.3 MILLION PER HOME.
THAT'S ALMOST AS BAD AS
MANHATTAN REAL ESTATE.
GOOD LORD, HAITI, IF YOU'RE
BLOWING $500 MILLION AT LEAST
BRIBE FIFA FOR THE 2026 WORLD
CUP.
THAT WOULD HAVE MADE SENSE.
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE THINKING,
LARRY, THE FACT THAT WE CAN'T
TRUST THE RED CROSS IS A SAD
STORY.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
IS IT SAD ENOUGH FOR THE TITLE
"JUST BECAUSE IT'S SAD DOESN'T
MEAN YOU CAN PRETEND IT'S NOT
HAPPENING"
>> Larry: GUYS, THAT'S
INAPPROPRIATE, THANK YOU.
HERE IS SOMETHING ELSE I WOULD
LOVE TO PRETEND ISN'T HAPPENING
IN HAITI.
>> IN HAITI WHERE THE UNs HAD
A PEACE KEEPING MISSION FOR
MORE THAN A DECADE.
THE SOLDIERS HAD TRANSACTIONAL
SEX WITH MORE THAN 200 WOMEN.
>> Larry: TRANSACTIONAL SEX.
THESE UN SOLDIERS ARE GETTING
HOOKERS WHEN THEY'RE SUPPOSE TO
DO RELIEF WORK.
THIS SOUNDS DISGUSTING.
BUT THE REALITY IS MORE
DISGUSTING.
>> INVESTIGATORS TALKED TO
HUNDREDS OF WOMEN IN HAITI AND
LIBERIA SAYING THEY HAD
TRANSACTUAL SEX FOR BASIC NEEDS
OF FOOD, SHELTER OR MEDICINE.
>> Larry: TRANSACTUAL SEX.
WHEN PEOPLE HAVE NOTHING ELSE TO
BARTER WITH BUT THEIR BODIES.
THE FACT IT'S BY PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUPPOSE TO KEEP PEACE IT'S
WORST.
IT'S LIKE A CARE BEAR ON A
MURDER SPREE.
MURDER SPREES ARE BAD.
CARE BEAR MURDER SPREES  ARE
MUCH WORST.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS, GUYS.
THAT'S WHY I TAKE INCREDULAX
SORRY. INCREDULOX:
FOR WHEN YOU SIMPLY CAN'T
BELIEVE IT AND IT'S COMPLETELY
TRUE AND YOU STILL CAN'T BELIEVE
IT.
AHH, GUESS WHAT THE UN HAS TO
SAY ABOUT THIS.
THEY PROHIBIT BARTERING FOR SEX
AND STRONGLY DISCOURAGES SEXUAL
RELATIONSHIPS.
OOH, DISCOURAGES.
THE BEST THE UN CAN DO IS A SIDE
EYE EMOJI.
THAT'S ALL WE GOT, SORRY.
BECAUSE GUESS WHY?
>> STAFF WITH LONG MISSION
EXPERIENCE STATED THERE WAS A
GENERAL VIEW PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
ROMANTIC RIGHTS.
>> Larry: GUYS, YOU'RE THERE TO
KEEP THE PEACE NOT GET A PIECE.
SERIOUSLY.
YOU WANT TO GET RID OF THE PENT
UP SEXUAL ENERGY GO BUILD SOME
[BEEP] HOMES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Larry: SORRY.
I NEEDED A LOT THERE.
OKAY.
OH, GOD.
LAST THING ABOUT THIS.
NOW IF THIS IS NOT SAD ENOUGH
FOR YOU.
>> Larry: STOP IT, STOP IT.
IF YOU THINK IT SUCKS TO BE A
HAITIAN IN THIS EARTHQUAKE.
IT SUCKS TO BE A HAITIAN RIGHT
NOW.
SAY YOU GOT OUT OF THE THIRD
WORLD HELL OF HAITI AND CROSSED
TO THE TWO A THIRD QUARTER WORLD
HELL THE DOMINICAN REPUBLIC FOR
A SLIGHTLY BETTER LIFE.
GUESS WHAT THE DR IS UP TO NOW.
>> HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
HAITIANS IN THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC ARE ROUNDED UP IN SO
CALLED WELCOME CENTERS AND
DEPORTED.
>> Larry: YES SENT BACK TO HAITI
WHERE SIX BEAUTIFUL HOUSES ARE
WAITING FOR YOUR ARRIVAL.
I LOVE THEY CALL THESE MAKESHIFT
INTERNMENT CAMPS "WELCOME
CENTERS."
THEY'RE LITERALLY THE OPPOSITE
OF CENTERS OF WELCOME.
IT'S LIKE CALLING WATER
BOARDING, GIGGLE SPLASHING.
OR CALLING SPIRIT AIRLINES,
SPIRIT AIRLINES INSTEAD OF
BREAK YOUR SPIRIT AIRLINES WHICH
IS WHAT IT IS.
OKAY, LOOK WHY ARE WE BRINGING
IT UP?
IT'S SIMPLE.
HAITI IS OUR NEIGHBOR.
LESS THAN A THOUSAND MILES FROM
FLORIDA.
I WISH WE COULD FORGET ABOUT
FLORIDA THE WAY WE FORGET ABOUT
HAITI.
FLORIDA, I'M KIDDING, BUT IT'S
TRUE.
IT'S SAD TO ME THAT THE ONLY
PERSON WE CAN RELY ON TO NOT
FORGET IS SEAN PENN WHO BUILT
HOUSING FOR 450 FAMILIES IN THE
SAME TIME IT TOOK THE RED CROSS
TO BUILD SIX.
THAT IS SAD.
I WILL GIVE SEAN PENN HIS PROPS.
ALRIGHT.
SO, THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: YES.
AGREE.
ALRIGHT.
NOW PLAY THE HAPPY MUSIC.